Daniel I understand that you are a huge
david fincher fans that's correct okay
so we have a quote here from David
Fincher so start our interview and if
this is from brainy quote so hopefully
it's correct it says this um some people
go to the movies to be reminded that
everything is okay I don't make those
kind of movies any thoughts on this
quote as it relates to your work I would
agree with that but I think that comes
from that goes much further back than
that that good drama to me is about
conflict so it has to be about stakes so
it very quickly tends to be about life
and death comforting you know the
feel-good movies are probably dealing
with that a little bit less than they
find other things that they're giving
the audience humor is kind of it
wholesomeness feeling i like the stakes
saying a lot and I think what Fincher
does really well with very few people do
is that you don't know whether it's
going to end well or badly like he has
made movies that have done either so if
I go and see a central movie today I
genuinely don't know if the protagonist
there's going to be okay at the end of
the movie and that is something that I
would love to have in my own movies
obviously hysterically ultimate suspense
to do that to an audience where I think
with most filmmakers 99% of filmmakers
you probably know that the protagonist
is going to be okay in the end and then
the other person you know that it's
going to be a dark ending horror ending
a kind of you know adventure has that
great balance so that's definitely
something to aspire to I think well they
say that most of these blockbuster films
are made for the Middle States and
they're made by people on either coast
and I'm butchering that quote but do you
think that most people who aren't in the
arts the people that maybe just want a
neat ending always feel that way I know
I'd ask someone who so they had a condo
in Park City and I said oh great you get
to go to Sundance and I have to worry
cuz I hate those movies
oh I said you do how could you hate
those I want to have a nice clear ending
I want to be happy I want to be
in the end ok I don't feel that way but
I think with me it depends on the day
there are days were very much feel that
way and I'm looking at a synopsis for a
movie and it sounds intelligent and
thought-provoking and I'd rather go to
the dentist and watch that movie on that
day because it's just being a too deep
it will involve me too much and some
days I want that kind of feel-good movie
and then there are other days my
favorite movie this year is the lobster
15 the incredible it's one of those
movies where from moment to moment you
have no idea what's going to be next but
every single one of them is
uncomfortable and but you you are so
engaged in what's going on because it's
a story that you have never lived
through before worse 99% of other
stories you've lived through before with
different actors with slightly different
storylines but you kind of are in
familiar waters I think as a movie can
put you in unfamiliar waters that itself
is such an achievement that it doesn't
matter whether it's a good ending or a
bad ending or whatever the experience
that you're being given for your $10 I
think is important every penny is it
because it sounds so trite but it's
about it reminds us of life but it's not
our life watching someone else go
through the fact that most human lives
that's our day we're never sure for a
moment moment is this going to turn out
well is the car in front of us going to
cut us off is this person actually not a
friend you know but that's life but then
we get to watch someone else go through
it and we get to take something away
from it I think what we really want to
do is that we see ourselves reflected in
that struggle so now and leave the
theatre with some insight that we didn't
have before and I don't know if it's
necessarily important that that
protagonist who was the vehicle for us
to have that inside it's a happy life
after the movie or doesn't lead a happy
life after the movie as long as I feel
it was a rich experience that makes me a
slightly different person walking out
than I was walking in but it's
interesting that you're saying that
about life because I always have
argument with genres because knife isn't
one genre life is funny and life is
scary and life is sexy and life is the
model all those things and yet movies
for some reason as marketing presses us
into this one genre we have to decide
the worst thing that can happen to us
when we develop stuff is that we are in
between genres that is unclear whether
it's a thriller or a drama like every
marketing person will immediately tell
you that it is poison and you have to go
I thought clearly the one way or the
other way and even if you don't
introduce it for a movie that is in
between genres they will make sure to
make it look like a specific genre they
will decide in marketing the marketing
department will say this is a thriller
and we just take the moment that looks
like a thriller and put them together
and I think that's when you get an
unhappy audience because they were
coming in with one mindset and then they
would either learn something else but I
always loved movies that stay within
their genre deliver that promise but
also give you sparkles of that real life
that actually jumps genres reminds me of
David Foster Wallace wrote the book
Infinite Jest
I didn't interview and he said he wrote
an article on going on a cruise which he
said was the most excruciating ly
painful experience for him because they
quote forced you to have fun right and
then they would check in are we having
fun yet and we're going to do all these
fun things on this itinerary for the day
does it almost feel like that with
certain films where they're forcing you
I think that is scary about the comedy
when they always say that comedies are
harder to make than anything else which
I believe because all the timing about
precision now that an inkling of the
looks easy and effortless but the other
thing is that the audience knows that
every moment what you're going for they
know in every moment you're trying to
make them love and have them have a good
time which in a drama or in a thriller I
don't have to be I don't have to lay my
cards on the table that much and say and
now I'm going to try to make you laugh
let's see if this works and every
failure blowing up - right in your face
yeah that's not the case maybe it was a
thriller a little bit because they know
you're trying to create suspense
but it's more over all over the entire
narrative kind of moment of effort
rather than a moment-by-moment effort
whereas in a comedy you know when a joke
doesn't land you know and it's painful
and I'm glad that I'm not making
comedies another have to subject myself
to that kind of inspection that reminds
me of - have a nice day t-shirt so for a
while that was really big and like maybe
late 70s 80s and then they were backlash
don't tell me what kind of data right
exactly and that's what you want from
your movies or at least you want movies
I think that's the whole manipulation
discussion I do think that storytelling
is inherently manipulative of course you
want the audience to have a certain
experience and you're trying as a
storyteller to get as much of a grip on
the audience to steer them through the
experience that you want them to have
but if they realize that you're doing
that I think there's a resistance that
they are going to put on the t-shirt
don't tell me what kind of data don't
tell me how to feel you know the worst
thing that can happen
I forget what I just saw that did that
is where the protagonist is always have
a step ahead of the audience emotionally
like that person is already crying
because something bad is happening but
as an audience I haven't caught up yet
so I don't get to actually experience
the sadness I only get to experience
that protagonists reaction to the
sadness and I immediately see my wall
going up and go look how the movie wants
me to feel sad screw you you know I'm
not going to feel upset and I think
that's another timing thing that goes
for every genre that you have to time
the experiences and the reactions of the
people in the story to what you think
will be the rhythm of the audience which
is really hard to predict I think that's
why editing when people always say the
films made and editing I think that's
definitely true for the rhythm of it all
because you have to anticipate when the
audience will arrive at what point and
when you can shoot the next particle of
information or emotion at them if you
get that wrong and it's like a dance
rhythm that is slightly off you know and
I think that's the difference between a
good editor and a bad editor and then
you do test screenings and then you
learn that
the audience dances two completely
different beast than you thought they
would and then you recut the whole thing
until you are kind of in step with your
audience well in between takes I think
you mentioned a book about editing that
was interesting in the blink of an eye
it's one of the required reading books
at the American Film Institute and
written by Walter Murch who's a very
famous editor and he has the theory that
we don't blink randomly but we kind of
blink when we digest a chunk of
information in our head you know and
that you should pay attention to your
blinking rhythm when you are watching
your edit and see if that kind of goes
along with the the exclamation marks at
the commas and all that in your movie
and that if you can watch an audience
watch your movie and look at their
blinking rhythm and you know whether
your story is well told or not depending
on whether that syncs up with your story
and I think that's even a theory in
dating that people whose blinking
doesn't sync up that they don't match
because their brains work differently
and process differently and I think
maybe you know that from your own life
if you were telling a story to someone
and that person blinks in the wrong
moment subconsciously you know that that
person is not really listening to your
story and you know that something's off
you know even if you can't put your
finger on it and I think what a merchant
that book kind of really focuses in on
that and explains that right I mean just
a side note I wear contacts so sometimes
I will blink because they're dry but
other than that that definitely makes
sense like let you see someone maybe
look up and I know there's different
theories on where someone looks when
they're telling you something as to
whether that's true or not but have you
watched people watch a cut of your film
and been conscious of their eyes all
their time oh yeah because I can for
some reason I can't not watch my own
movie if it's a screening but I'll do a
Q&A after I can't because other people
just go get a drink and come back for
the Q&A into the Q&A I was at the
feeling I have to
watch the movie with that audience -
he'll get a feeling for their experience
often so that I know we're talking about
the same movie because every audience
weirdly I haven't figured out why has a
different experience watching the exact
same movie and you can tell that they
are laughing at different moments you
can tell that they're in suspense in
different moments I don't know why that
is there some highest group dynamic
going on so the means really interesting
- to see a movie with that audience and
then I'm watching their reactions a lot
in the dark you know like a creep
without them knowing and sometimes I see
them blink at the wrong moments and I'm
like oh man I wish I had known that
earlier I'm using them in that in that
moment or that look the same as if there
was a joke in there and the audience
doesn't laugh and you gotta get the joke
not work or did you lose them somewhere
along the line completely so that they
didn't even realize that there was a
joke you know so it's it's a terrifying
experience watching your movie with an
audience for sure but the blinking the
blinking helps I think it depends to
what type of an audience if you're
watching it with people who are within
the industry let's say they're
journalists they see three movies a week
I think maybe there's a desensitization
a little bit whereas if you watched with
people that they work nine to five jobs
and that's their entertainment for the
Friday night they're going to be giddy
and having fun it's at the comedy but or
if they want to be scared they're going
to be maybe more high you know because
they want to feel something true but of
course ideally that the hope would be
that you can penetrate that cynicism
that you've created a story that is
interesting enough and surprising enough
and strong enough emotionally that even
the guy that watches three movies a day
because it's his job and kind of hates
having to watch another one if you can
get that guy to forget that that this
job for an hour and a half you know and
send him on the journey that he didn't
even want to go onto I think then you
have strong movie I don't know if I've
made that movie yet but I know that
that's kind of the goal that it's not
audience dependent but it's so strong
narrative Lee that it would grab anyone
that you would have to be deaf dumb and
blind to not
affected by well that wine I sat next to
journalist who has literally jumped out
of their chair at certain point so that
not to say and that was my bad that
their disaffected but I think in some
cases we've just seen so much that you
know it is I can put the narrative and
the glittering phenolic right but with
this book do you remember reading it
do you remember and what besides the the
rhythm but to me that's just fascinating
now I'm going to be very conscious of
that even in just daily life but then
you're screwed
because I wouldn't say I feel really
good book I was know I'm going to have
to pay attention when to blink and
suddenly you're blinking rhythm you look
natural anymore and you've lost already
so you got to get that out of your head
again as quickly as possible and then
you developing your edit in your movie
that's true yet that's where sometimes
ignorance ignorance is bliss because if
you if you know too much about like
micro expressions and things like that
then you're kind of like Hunan another
being sincere but when you went to AFI
that was required reading and you
remember how different it was for you
after you finish the book how you
approached being in the editing room and
watching even other students see a rough
cut of your films I think it just blends
and you're bombarded with so much stuff
because there were 50 books on that
required reading this so there's all
this stuff that I think you don't you
don't concentrate on one particular
thing you've learned that then you apply
it right there but it's this this
library of big stuff that were kind of
rear its head the details over their
heads hopefully when they are required
and some of the time you don't even know
which but you have a feeling for oh I
remember something about that and I
think was that it was like that I can't
remember specifically sitting in the
editing room and going like let me look
at my editor and count how often she
blinks to see that we're on the same
page so is making the same movie you
know it's just something kind of vaguely
remember
I think who you watch a movie to in a
theater with plays a big role because I
remember we watched a film and the only
other person in the theatre you know the
night was a celebrity and I won't say
who it was but they were there to
support the filmmaker and that person
was laughing but and I found myself
laughing and then I'm like wait a minute
am I just trying to like join in with
this person is that the reason in love
but it was a great experience and it was
surreal being this huge theatre with the
one famous person watching this film
with the point interrogator it was not
but I can say that because I have seen
that movie of mine actually it wasn't
supposed to be funny
oh no but he had such a good time I
don't know if that's a good thing or
that they got he was laughing from the
first to the last minute as I what does
that mean and he could tell that the
rest of the audience was confused
because it he has a very succinct laugh
you can tell it's Tarantino you know so
if he thinks it's funny then they
probably were wondering should I think
it's funny and those got a little weird
energy throughout the movie was really
interesting how that probably has to do
with that hype dynamic again with a
group dynamic that everyone there is
there is the desire to be on the same
page with your fellow human beings kind
of thing and I think that's why embodies
everyone in an audience is kind of
trying to have the same experience and
not be too far off from the tribe
--kavitha and that's maybe why comedies
work so much better with a big audience
rather than with a small audience
because there's that confusion it's like
all everyone else is having fun so I
should have fun too and then there's a
the subconscious kind of tendency
towards me you never got an answer as to
why certain parts were funny
due to the tangent thing right and I
talked about to him afterwards and he
you know he talked about all this stuff
but I don't think I got it worked and to
ask what he thought was coming
hmm I know sometimes if we go to a
theater to watch a movie it's usually a
mainstream film that's more again sort
of a bedroom community and these aren't
people in the industry and what I'll do
is I'll clap at the end to see how many
people clap because usually within when
you go to a Hollywood film
or something around this area people are
all on the industry or they know someone
and they realize the hard work that the
people behind the scenes put in they'll
clap and I'm surprised and sometimes
David teases me how many people don't
clap right and they just gather chairs
groan and they were like okay where do
we go get cake and coffee after this
right and and I just find that
interesting that is so dependent in the
area I have that with flights you know
how sometimes people clap off a plane
and we made it we didn't when I first
heard that maybe that's an American
thing because I think I was 35 years old
when I first said on a plane where
people are clapping and I was like what
did people expect are we celebrating
this outcome you know and it's kind of
the same with I think with a movie that
you expect the filmmakers that have had
a budget of millions of dollars and the
audience has just each paid their good
money to see that story that they take
it as a given that they are being
delivered a good time over those two
hours and that I feel like they
shouldn't have to celebrate that they
weren't screwed over and robbed of their
money so I can I can understand the
mindset of of not clapping after a movie
and I actually have that when the movie
was really good
I can't clap or worse even talk to
people afterwards like if you're really
affected by something it goes so far
you're in a different place
you're not clipping or like if you're
clapping the movie hasn't 100% gotten
you maybe if it's a comedy that's a
different thing but if it's a large
country or breaking the waves afterwards
that got you you would not clap you know
because clapping means you are aware
exactly what you were saying aware of
the work that has been done right but if
the work has been done brilliantly
you're not even aware of the work that
has been done you were just flattened by
the story and by the characters that you
just experienced you don't think about
directors writers photographers stuntmen
all the stuff behind the scenes because
you're so impressed by the narrative
that you just experienced I didn't know
I felt that way about clapping until we
just talked about it but that's maybe
why
I can understand that people don't clap
I don't know for one of my own movies I
would rather have people clap or not
clap I know that my first movie was the
fake documentary about suicide no one
ever clapped after that movie and I
would have been I was known that I had
failed if they had clapped after that
you know where as with the other movies
where it was more of an upbeat ending or
it's not that dark it probably would
have been okay for people to clap which
they didn't they're either maybe I'm
just making bad movies I don't know what
it is I don't experience except outside
a festival audience you know I think I
testicles because people assume that
what some of the filmmakers are there
there's the polite kind of claps but I
don't think I've ever experienced it
that the audience was clapping
afterwards memory telling interesting
[Music]
sort of survey for artists that make
films would you be offended if someone
clapped after your movie or would you
take it as a compliment depends on the
movie it depends on the state you want
to put people into going back to the
insurer at the end of seven but whether
people are clapping or not clapping and
whether you want that or not probably
depends on the story that you were just
telling that the emotion that you were
hoping to put the audience into the
Fincher quickly just because we had that
example earlier for seven you know you
want the audience to be so distressed
and destroyed that he probably wouldn't
want anyone clapping at the end of the
movie I think he would have known in a
test screen but something is wrong with
this movie whereas there are probably
other movies you know that are more
upbeat and have a different energy true
and I am thinking back to the ones that
I have clapped out recently and they
were not sort of tease and melancholy
ending so yeah that does make sense
well it's 2016 August 2016 summer day in
LA we know why father needed to say that
but we were but we met with you the
first time in 2012 which and that was
about four years ago so since that time
a lot has happened in your life you've
been a part of projects different things
have you become more idealistic about
filmmaking
so more realistic about what is needed
to work in Hollywood have you had any
kind of great question have you talked
to people that get more idealistic as
their career growth I always talked
about it because it's an interesting
question because after we last met I
think I was just in preparation for a
movie I think I was just about to shoot
13 sins which is my last feature film I
haven't made a feature film since then
and such a thing you're asking whether I
got more idealistic or less I think it's
a mixture of both because I'm very proud
of 13 cents but it never went anywhere
it made 9 thousand dollars at the box
office and it came after Last Exorcism
which was this you can discuss whether
that's a better film or a worse film or
whatever but box office wise it was a 70
million dollar success going to in
$9,000 complete failure at the box
office right which I would claim I have
nothing to do with either not with that
success and not with that failure
because it's marketing and how much
money is being pumped into stuff last
exorcism had a marketing budget of 24
million dollars so it's easier job of
course to get people to see it and to
make that kind of money 13 cents didn't
have a single dollar of marketing budget
and that depended on without pointing
fingers but it depends on who buys your
movie of course and that in that case
the company that bought the movie just
before 13 cents was going to be released
had a huge flop with a movie that they
had big hopes for and had done a big
marketing campaign for and they were
just out of money they did not have the
capacity of getting 13 cents released
theatrically you know so suddenly you
are a VOD movie which is not a problem
but it is a difference of course in if
you see the chart of your career the way
it's perceived you're going from you
know the worldwide theatrical movie to
the VOD movie in America which means
that nowhere else in the world it's
going to go theatrical so suddenly you
have a movie that is you know basically
disappearing which has nothing to do
with its quality just as this success
didn't necessarily have anything to do
with its quality you know but of course
you are being held
countable so I then kind of had to see
where to get my next paycheck from
because suddenly I am NOT this film
market maker anymore because Hollywood
as always your worth as much as your
last project made at the box office
basically so I was worth this much of
the Last Exorcism and it was worth this
much after 13 things which is a real
problem to get yourself out of so the
answer is TV you know and I was always
like I don't want to do TV I don't know
do TV but hey I had to get my rent check
from somewhere and B I think the
landscape really changed maybe I'm just
telling myself that because now I'm
doing to me but I think a lot has
happened since we last spoke in terms of
TV with true detective with Game of
Thrones that some of the best
storytelling to that today is being done
in TV so I'm not actually as bleak a
world as I would have thought back then
that TV is but what has been interesting
about TV concurs in terms of being
disillusioned on it is that it is a
completely different medium because your
role as a director is a completely
different one like it shouldn't even be
called saying they should make up a new
word I think for it because in a movie
in a future film you create the world
from scratch like you cast your people
you could make every decision the
costumes the locations all of that from
scratch you work on the script you put
your team together you are responsible
for everything and you know not that all
every idea is yours but you are the
filter through which everyone else's
ideas are filtered and you as the
director
other one that goes yes no yes yes no
you know in TV you come on board with a
script that the DGA says you need to
have 24 hours before principal
photography so sometimes you get a
script as you get on the plane you read
the script on the plane it's very clear
because the script is already such a
political document because it's been in
development with the network with a
production company with the showrunner
or with
or finance here but this is already the
compromise document that everyone agreed
on the last thing they want is your
opinion about anything as director it's
very clear direct what's on the page so
that's the first difference then the
actors are already cast all the sets are
already built in the studio they already
are wearing what they have been wearing
for the last couple of episodes in a
future film you are the one that knows
most about the story and knows most
about the world it's set in and that is
where you get all your authority and
strength from you don't have to pull the
director card because you have substance
because you have set with the story for
solar in TV it's the exact opposite you
know the less about everything than
anyone else who is there and who has
worked on all the other episodes but
everybody knows that including the
actors and the showrunner which I wasn't
even clear on the concept when I did my
first episode that there is a show
runner who has overseen the writing
concept and is the authority on set and
who is actually making the decisions
it's not you as the director because at
first I was always election
I like that decision you know we're a
production meeting we're in a feature
film environment you would get asked
thousand questions from all the
department heads and suddenly I was in a
production meeting for TV where I wasn't
asked single question because well I
could I was auditing the production
being more than a thing and then there's
another thing at TV which is called the
tone medium which I also wasn't familiar
with I saw on the schedule tonight told
meeting so I showed up for the tone
meeting I was like I wonder what that
should I prepare something what is it
it's basically where the writers sit you
down and go through the script scene by
scene and explain to you what is
important what every scene and what they
need you to deliver and they will tell
you about every actors weaknesses and
strengths and about you know be careful
that that doesn't happen hit and you
basically take notes and then you go and
set and you try to deliver that and at
first it was a real kind of switch that
you had to make in your creative ego
because you
so used I was so used to being the
creative authority on set and at least
have the last word
not with a budget obviously something
outside of the budget the producer will
have the last word and very quickly tell
you what you can counter but within the
creative process I was the one who got
to make the decisions with TV it's more
like you are an advisor who can voice
suggestion but whether that is being
done depends on if it falls on you know
fruitful ground or not with a showrunner
with the actors and because the actors
are very aware that you are not the
authority they have no problem saying
like no I won't do that and so you are
in a position where you can't plan very
much because you can only in a movie you
can plan because you can count on the
people that you past making a concerted
effort to execute what you're trying to
do in TV there might be one or two
people that just know their character
better and they protect that character
which are completely understand because
they're dealing with a different
director every week and if they
completely did what every director
wanted to show wouldn't have any
continuity and consistency so they have
to protect that but that also means if I
go in with a rigid plan I will just hit
a wall and that'll be the end of it you
know so after I got through that first
shock where was like what am I actually
because I want to be a good director
I've been hired I want to do my job I
want to be worth the money they're
paying me what do they actually do if I
came to set I did the blocking that's
the one thing you get to do every TV
director you get to suggest where
everyone should stand and where everyone
should move if I drop dead after that I
don't think anyone would notice until
the end of the day if someone else
called action everyone that it's amazing
but that was the disillusion that I
worked delusion dissolution with with
the professionalism in yeah where you're
like this is not the creative process
I went to film school for and I kind of
want to put both in my head right now
but then I realized that the greatest
film school you could ever go through
because you
have to deliver something within a world
that has been created and it's like this
training exercise because you have to
understand what that world is what the
rules of that world are what the tone of
that world is and you have almost no
time to understand how every actor works
because with a movie you have rehearsal
time that you there's much more time to
warm up with people
whereas in TV you have minutes before
you are shooting your first take and
then you have one or two takes and then
you have to move on in a movie you do
like Fincher 40 takes you know there's
always something interesting here the
actors have prepared their performance
which then a movie doesn't happen I
think in the movie the movie actor
prides themselves or herself to come to
set at a blank slate
you know and then just try stuff and you
could put your heads together and the
joy is to experiment and find things
together and TV you don't have that
because you don't have the time you're
absurd in a 45 minute episode in six
days there is no time for
experimentation so they come with a
wizard performance that they have
thought of in their hotel rooms and they
show it to you and you get one tweak
maybe two and if you want more than that
everything comes to a standstill and
there's this atmosphere of something's
wrong you know we're out of sync or
something and everyone gets insecure and
the showrunner comes in and makes the
decision so I kind of quickly had to
learn that is it completely different
rhythm you know and the problem is that
by the time that you have earned your
actors trust and I get that that's a
very valid process for them to go
through the shoot is over like on every
episode where I have 6 days by day 6
I have the feeling now we all trust each
other we know what we're capable of and
now we could go off and make a movie
together or make an episode together or
ever the problem is that we just made
the episode say that while that wasn't
necessary ok so it's a great it's a
great environment to try your own
directing abilities because you have to
be fast and you get to try a lot of
stuff and this
that goes wrong you don't feel quite as
connected to the final creative outcome
as you would in a movie that you have
been working on for two years so it
gives you a certain freedom with the
movie if I Drive to set in the morning
I'm nauseous because I'm so nervous
because everything if anything doesn't
work out that day then it's on me you
know where's Ben in TV the machine is
already running someone has this great
analogy actually the showrunner of the
first show that I did he said in movies
you hold the steering wheel like this
type you know and with the TV show it's
more this where you kind of gingerly
gather and that's exactly what it is and
it's like to stay with the car analogy
it's like that the movie is like a stick
shift I think where if you don't press
the gas that will just stand and nothing
will happen well it was an automatic if
you don't do anything it kind of slowly
drives anyway and that is what the TV
show is I think a TV show could direct
itself without a director probably and
would more or less look the same whereas
a movie would just fall apart if there
weren't a directly and that took a
little bit to learn but by now I'm
having a lot of fun doing TV exactly
because of these limitations because
every so fast you're in and out you know
it's as if you are getting into the six
day training camp with people you don't
know as a team you've never worked
together worthless so much harder for
you have no idea what his style is do
you have very little time to learn what
he's been doing with the other seasons
the other episode and you have to work
within that environment and adjusting to
that is I think a really good exercise I
think it's made me a much better
director whenever I get to make my next
feature film
I think TV you will have been a good
exercise and training camp
going back to something you said about
how you came off the success of one film
and then another film that you enjoyed
making you felt it wasn't as successful
in some sense though don't you think
that that then further prepares you and
makes that you draw that line in the
sand knowing that that's the ebb and
flow of being an artist as an ebb and
flow of having a brand of being in a
band that you're going to have some that
are perceived one way and some that
aren't but if you really still want to
do this you get back and you do it again
and you know that that's kind of the
risk that's a very mature way of looking
at it I thought that if I had that
maturity you know oh are you you just
because you're just furious because it's
out of your hand
we put as much time it was the same team
as the other movie we put edge as much
time and love into this movie as we did
into the other movie and then to see a
company do nothing with it for whatever
reasons financial I wasn't that they
didn't love the movie or anything but
you're just helped us it was profound
feeling of helplessness and are going to
give people could only see this movie I
think they would appreciate it you know
and fit so I don't know if I had the
distance to go like oh that is just the
ebb and flow of the creative process
that's beautifully put because it gives
us that poetry but I didn't experience
it at poetry in the moment I think right
well and believe me this is not like how
I dictate my life every day either I
mean every all get upset over something
not working out but I think if you have
time to reflect on it and say because
I've known a lot of people that have
been frustrated and said nope I'm done
leaving or tired of this it didn't work
this person it is that but if you know
that if you could have some distance
somehow bring in a paycheck however that
is and then go okay this might be part
of how someone sustains a career show
now here I'm sure that that is probably
true that if you can't deal with the
failures you won't have a career for
sure for sure now with me I don't it's
one of those cases where I'm not really
good at anything else I don't know what
else my career as I could play the
guitar and we'll try the rock star
career out of that so I know that I'll
stick with
with narrative storytelling in whatever
form whether that's TV or movies or
whatever so that at least when I panic
and I'm frustrated I don't go out of
outside of that box and go like let me
become a gardener or something I'm
staying within the you know what can we
do within it and it's kind of the same
thing though you want to work with
material that you find stimulating and
interesting and that's not generic and
then it's almost secondary where it ends
up
I mean of course it's nicer if it ends
up on the big screen at the ArcLight and
you know on 3000 screen then on VOD on
itunes or something but really the
creative process that you go through
this absolutely exactly the same and
also to sorry enriching that that
knowing there isn't really anything else
you have a desire to do because I heard
someone say about the other day like oh
I'm not trained for something else but I
know that person is bright enough to do
whatever they put their mind you know
what it's having that impetus to get you
out of bed to do that but it's the only
thing that gets you out of bed is
knowing that okay I have a 6:00 a.m.
call time and I'll I'll get ready for
this those are the days I can I prefer
to stay in bed but when I have a 6:00
a.m. call about it now if you're your
own I've always stated this dignity with
your cultural German thing that I always
think like today is the day when
everything will go wrong and everything
will fall apart every night after shoot
I'm genuinely surprised I'm going to
today went really well
we got away with it one morning tomorrow
is going to be a catastrophe but to stay
with it and then when I think back I
don't think I've ever had a bad shooting
day where I didn't go home and was like
today was amazing and yet I always fall
for that that I'm terrified of the next
day of not being prepared for the next
day and I think like project after
project I get a little bit better at
letting go
I just got it's this thing you know and
going like whatever will happen I have
to be a hundred percent prepared because
I've been doing it long enough or I'm
working with people that have been doing
it long enough that we can
react to things that don't go completely
according to plan yeah but that's a very
slow process to kind of for that to sink
into my bones and for me not to be
terrified in the morning everyone that's
good in some ways I mean there's an
overconfidence in American culture I
think that we've been groomed to be all
why I got this
you know we're going to do this that's
Shawn you know I wish I had that I would
take good money for some of that
confident it has a good time and it's
bad sides I think like with my pessimism
usually I am over prepared you know so
that's a good thing but on the other
hand if I look back at that shoes now we
had such a good time and I'm kind of
like I wish I had enjoyed that more and
not my head has my brain being terrified
of what tomorrow might bring like if I
had known the outcome in advance I would
have enjoyed the journey much more so
I'm now trying to consciously do that
even with with difficulties because I'm
so privileged how great to see these
things how great to see a genuine
Hollywood diva being difficult and being
a nightmare from the first role you know
how great of course at that moment you
don't feel that way you just go like
that woman is destroying my life and I
don't know how to do the scene because
she's being difficult but if I can just
step back and go like I get to spend my
workday seeing that first rate data I
wouldn't want to do anything else right
you can pull out the ebb and flow card
we're exactly like an episode or t-shirt
you sort of have a nice day that hasn't
slowed
have another quote for you it is just a
ton of quotes this one is from Maxwell
Maltz and it reads often the difference
between a successful man and a failure
is not one's better abilities or ideas
but the courage that one has to bet on
his ideas to take calculated risk and to
app excuse me into act so do you relate
to that I can read it again if you want
I kind of put it on you I think it helps
if the idea is good to begin with you
know confident that we're talking about
that earlier I think confidence does
help a lot but if your idea is bad then
being persistent and and loud about it
they're going to get you that far either
like I like people a lot that are
quieter and have great ideas and I have
to I know I have to take good attention
because they won't point out how great
their ideas are so I have to kind of
listen because I know the diamonds are
in there and they won't scream them into
my face but it's probably true that a
lot of great ideas just die because
someone doesn't have that feeling to
project it to the world or the
persistent it's also hard because the
first couple of reactions might be
negative that you get to something you
know where you are pitching it to
someone and maybe the pitch of how you
describe the idea isn't completely
worked out yet and you're just trying
out and then you get negative feedback
and I could imagine that that shops a
lot of people down I think that the very
sensitive seeing your audience for your
unfinished ideas is something that
people maybe are not as conscious about
si should be that it's as if you are
carrying as if you're giving someone a
raw egg and you kind of want to know
that they will be careful with that raw
egg and not just destroy because they
don't get it or because they they want
their opinion in there quicker there's
also in test screenings I think there
are different groups of people but one
group of people is always they won't
tell you what they think about your
movie they will tell you what movie
they would have made or wish you had
made and you always want to say like
that's not the movie I made you know so
I think if you if you come with an idea
to that crowd then you will get
discouraged very soon but on the other
hand there is the danger of not going
out with an unfinished idea to a test
audience early enough and kind of
keeping it being very protective of it
and working on it
and and not wanting to expose it to the
world until you feel it's the best
version of what it can be and then when
you show to the world they will react to
it and you'll go like oh damn I wish I'd
heard that comment four weeks ago when
it was still flexible and I could still
do something with it now it's so rigid
and the whole thing will fall apart if I
integrate that idea that I just heard
from someone but back then it would have
changed everything so I think over the
years I've gone out to people earlier
and earlier and by now with the very
first idea and see how they respond
because it is it can change so much and
just to bounce people off of ideas off
of people I think is a huge valuable
tool and to know people well enough to
know in what ways they are bouncing it
back to you do you have to put on the
extrovert hat when you do that being an
introvert or being more internal not
necessarily the extrovert ahead because
I'm not a Salesman that the idea can't
sell itself in that moment then it's
probably not a good idea but you
definitely need a thick skin like
there's nothing I never feel more
humiliated and stabbed in the back then
after a test screening but that's what
test screenings are for you know you
don't make a test interviewed on invite
people to test screening just for
everyone to say like that was great have
a good day yeah he wants them to say I
was bored
I was offended that didn't work that
didn't work what the hell were you
thinking about and to hear that from 20
people whether they're your best friends
or strangers doesn't matter it's always
an emotional catastrophe because I think
a story puts out your view of the world
out there no matter what that story is
the way you handle perform
since the way you the editing rhythm
because a color scheme everything about
it
always revealed something about you as a
person and how you see the world so now
you present that and you are suddenly
the raw egg you know if you so you don't
have any protection against it and
everyone is just bashing it in a and
making you feel like you are on the
dumbest person in the world they don't
attend to them they have the feeling
they are very sensitive and careful but
of course what you are here and you
don't hear any of the positive stuff you
only hear what is me I only hear the
negative stuff so I'm never more
depressed than the night after a test
screen but it always is one of the most
important steps that Jessica the first
one a catastrophe just get through it
it's like a traffic accident and then
test grading by test screening it gets a
little better a little better a little
better and I think the the goal at first
when I was test grading my first movie I
thought the goal was to make all
negative comments go away like I know I
have a great movie and I've tested it
enough if no one has anything negative
to say about it anymore which is
nonsense because you could do that into
the end of time and it wouldn't ever
happen so by now it's like if everyone
has a different complaint about the
movie then I know I have a good movie it
just has to be a different complaint
from everyone if that person hates the
movie for that reason if that movie that
guy hates that actor in and that guy
hates the score and that good that's
okay as long as it's not twenty-five
people hating the same actor or the same
score or the same whatever you just want
it kind of to spread the criticism and
to dissolve himself that there was a
learning process to arrive there that
you'll never have a completely positive
feedback to anything well going back to
the quote that I opened the question was
can you think of any calculated risk
that you've taken you know since your
time you know you came out here you went
to AFI
any calculated risk knowing that you you
do think things and I relate to that
school thought it's not a criticism
believe me I'm very much in that same
camp but when you overthink and you want
to make sure that you planting
can you think of any time were you
because I just heard a quote in a
documentary that I saw and the guy said
you know directors are the reckless
people that's a lot of it's interesting
because the reckless isn't necessarily a
bad thing
it can actually I just had a
conversation with the director friend of
mine where we were both saying a
variation of that which was directors
are arrogant people because we assume
that we have something to say to the
world that is worth having millions
pumped into it we have a message for the
world that will be so valuable to the
world but someone should give us five
million dollars so that we can tell it
that's that's delusional if you think
about it that is like a crazy crazy
mindset and yet directors have that I
don't know where it's coming from or why
people accept it or what it is but we
both were in agreement that we're kind
of off that way or that that the idea is
kind of off you have to believe in your
own abilities or how special you are or
your ideas or something - to a degree
that is not normal I think and that's
not the same as self-confidence because
I don't think I'm a very self-confident
person definitely not an extrovert
another director personality necessarily
myself but there's something where an
idea drives you and doesn't let you
sleep and just grabs you and once to be
hurt somehow and then you become the
vehicle of that idea and maybe that is
what gives you the impetus to say like
it's not just me thinking but I'm a
genius and I can tell the story it's
like a story wants to be told and it
doesn't leave me alone so I'll have to
do that that's more my experience right
so keeping the same vein what if someone
told Elan musk you know these ideas that
you're having about this car and some of
this you know and to just you pipe down
just just why don't you go work for a
manufacturer well I don't think it would
do any harm
it has had successes I'm sure it's
dangerous is when it's your first step
into unknown territory and you know that
unknown territory it's something you've
never done and you're coming out of your
shell and you're out of your comfort
zone and then that person whoever that
person is comes up and say why don't you
do a B and C that is dangerous if then
people listen to it because there has to
be failure in the beginning right and
there has to be and that's why film
school is maybe one of the big passes I
think student Kings said that in the
book that he wrote about film making
that he said the one advantage she can
see in film schools is that you can call
yourself a filmmaker but no one can
laugh at you and you have the space and
room to fail and I wish I had seen that
in film school because I was so tense in
film school it all felt like as if you
can win film school you know field
school shouldn't be there to be won or
for you to be the most talented in your
class and to show the world and show
Hollywood it should really be and I
think they're doing good job trying to
protect it as much as possible there
should be a time where you are allowed
to try stuff and fail and see what
doesn't work said that edison quote
where he said he felt 900 methods to not
invent a light bulb at dinner before he
found the one that that actually worked
such a saying there yeah so I think that
if the ELA mask would probably be fine I
won't be too worried about illamasqua
this one I think you said before don't
worry about making it pretty I think
that's interesting and is that part of
what you talked about in film school
that it made it okay to like fail and
making something don't worry about
making it pretty I mean the process is
messy I think something someone talked
about the parallel to making sausage
you know everyone when you later talk
about your movie is done and then you
hear people talk about the process it
sounds so beautiful it sounds like they
were on vacation they always were all
the same opinion it was just a creative
melting of the mind
everyone was supportive of each other
that's not what it's like you know it's
it's war there are people that you love
and people that you hate and you have
all this helps out in the world and more
often than not you you have a feeling
you've no idea what you're doing it
always feels like there was a plan and
then they executed the plan and now
there is the movie you know but it's
this quote that there are how does it go
three movies one that you write one that
you shoot one that you edit I think
that's very true like my movies I never
expect it to be the outcome better or
worse than what they then became but I
think ideally there will be the the
product the movie the story itself will
take its own check on its own lives and
will have its own life force and tell
you what it wants to be and I think that
that's where a lot of people where it's
hard to listen to that because you're so
tense and you are so unsure of yourself
that you don't want to release that
power and go or let's just see what
happens you want to execute your plan
you know and that's where you hit the
wall because you won't be able to
completely 100% execute your plan you
need that a little bit of flexibility to
go like oh it wants to be funny in that
moment let it you know and then test
screen it and see it destroys everything
else which I might but at least gives
and that goes for everything gives the
actors the room to give you something
else than what you had in your head
before gives the production designer the
Scimitar refer gives everyone enough
we're going to to breathe and to
contribute and I think they will catch
on to that very quickly whether you are
someone who just wants to have stuff
executed their vision and you don't
really want people to contribute you
know you just want them to fill in the
blueprint that you may or do you want
them to contribute and I think the the
atmosphere on set is night and day and I
think we talked about that four years
ago that if you stick to your plan then
all of it and you're a genius that's
great but if you're not you have a
problem because everything will only be
filtered through your one mind and your
one angle you know
we'll be blind spots that you can't can
do anything about
where if you give everyone else the
opportunity to to creatively contribute
you know and work together suddenly it's
ten minds kind of putting their
processing power together and that way
you eliminate I think a lot of blind
spots that otherwise you only see and
test screenings and maybe when it's too
late and you can't reach you whereas if
everyone was inspired to take ownership
of the project which is why I don't
really believe in this a film by and
then the directors name is always kind
of weird to me because if that is the
case then they worked in a very
different way of what I work like or of
my above what my movies come together is
because there are so many people
contributing and the movie would feel
different if you already exchange one of
these people it will be a contributed on
movie for your movie thirteen sins you
were hired by Jason Blum well now okay
productions one house productions so
where did you meet him I met him in his
office know everything how did the two
heads let me let me go back I guess I
had the two of you come in contact with
each other I've got an email from my
agent that said Jason Blum would like to
meet you and then I went and met and he
had ten different projects because Jason
Blum is producing you know juggling all
these project at the same time and he
was basically just pitching first of all
he's this rock-and-roll personality but
have you ever met him I have no I know
he's amazing like you boots on the table
and another the executive the way I'm
great and very fun very high-energy and
he pitched me all these projects and I
didn't really connect to any of them and
he created an atmosphere that was loose
enough and friendly and warm enough that
I felt I could say that I could say I
don't I'm not interested in that story
never and when he was done with those
ten he kind of talked over my shoulder I
was like do you want to show him 13 I
turned around and realized if there was
someone else sitting in the corner
that I haven't seen before that which
was Brian Cavanaugh Jones who is the
producer Arthur Jensen and they gave me
the original time movie 13 Game of Death
to watch and that was the end of the
meetings and then I watched 13 Game of
Death I wasn't I loved the movie but I
wasn't too excited about making remake
no one ever wants to make a remake
necessarily you know they're saying they
do they they're lying but I couldn't at
the time I was working with my channel
on the time on a on a project and I I
knew I had to do something soon because
there's this pressure and Hollywood that
they will all forget about you if you
don't make something within a year or
something your career will be over
expect what your agents tell you so I
knew I had to find a new project and I
just couldn't find material that I was
interested in and 13 sins or 13 Game of
Death at the time or something that I
always had in the back of my head and I
liked the material and the only thing
that spoke against it was that it was a
remake and then I thought if we can make
this different enough and make it our
own and not just me and shoot it shot by
shot then it's going to be interesting
project and so I said yes to that if I
could bring on board eight of Burke who
had written last exorcism or rewritten
last exorcism for me and with whom I was
writing with Anna Chapman at the time it
was a complete genius who by now is
writing pother Evans new movie and
daniel espinosa those mini movie Robert
Rodriguez's new movie and he has
completely blown up he should be sitting
here telling you about his career Dudley
but they let me bring him on board and
we wrote a new script David wrote a new
script which was rich and what was fun
about it is that the structure of $0.13
kind of had this episodic structure
because there are 13 challenges that the
protagonist goes through so you could
create a completely new world for every
one of these challenges where normally
in a movie there like one or two big set
pieces and the rest is just kind of
connected tissue
there was 13 set pieces yeah so that was
really enticing about the material and
then jason blum loved it and then Bob
Weinstein loved it and bought it and
then we went to New Orleans to make the
movie that's a sea and this story now
feels very clean and if it was just this
Pleasant Road from A to B when of course
you know it was a one-year process of
sweat and tears and blood not between us
but just in the movie making process and
the movie turned out completely
differently from what anyone else
thought but I think better you know but
but that's all I'm talking about when
people talk about the movies that it
always feels like it was such a smooth
journey it never was a smooth journey it
was always an adventure
and fascinating and I would do it again
in a heartbeat but it was never smooth
you think that's why some people don't
come back because they thought it was
going to be one thing whatever the movie
is and it ends up being not hard to
darkness type triumphs that people are
going through you know Apocalypse Now or
and in dealing with also seems from
opposition from the government things
like that but you know something where
it just wasn't what you thought you know
you're ruminating late at night thinking
like though this can't happen and he
thought it was going to be where you
heard birds chirping and Brooks I have a
friend who's a very talented director
who just made her first movie and who
said that's a beautiful movie the
outcome is gorgeous named actors great
and she said I have no desire to ever do
that again she just was she said she
could not deal with the feeling of being
the King on a throne making the
decisions led to her what most other
directors are craving what you can get
addicted to
yeah that is exactly what turned her off
she was like I don't want to have that
relationship with anyone ever like to
her as much as she was trying to build a
collaborative atmosphere on set I think
it could never be collaborative enough
she always had the feeling she was the
leader of something
didn't want to be the leader she wanted
to be she's amazing
but I said yeah and I'd never heard that
from anyone but there was that they had
too much power on set and that's why
they wouldn't do another movie but she
is that person that makes complete sense
and she might not ever make another
movie I think maybe if she gets over the
experience and most people have to
forget the bad experiences to make a
movie again she kind of has to forget
the powerful experience of it all to do
it again so I'm sure that a lot of
people don't make a second movie because
they are surprised by how much hostility
from the elements from from everything
they are bombarded with and they have to
get through I'm not sure where I'm going
with this but I'll just say it so
there's this book called quiet the power
of extroverts Susan Cain introverts
introverts of I just answered I just
bought it because I am an introvert my
wife is an introvert and we're having a
daughter in a month and I'm like that
girl is going to be the introvert of
introverts I better get that book active
is it been it's excellent and she does
these case studies of going into Harvard
Business School she goes into another
religious college Tony Robbins seminar
and just how much in in this culture
were were pushed to be these gregarious
larger-than-life personality so just
relating that back to your friend
wondering if maybe she felt the pressure
to be that and that's very draining if
you're an extra or if you're an
introvert like you you don't always want
to be on level ten but I think people
really resonate especially in LA to that
and probably other other metropolitan
cities resonate to that meaning that
they are turned towards the extrovert
yeah they respond to and whereas if
you're too in the background
oh they is everything okay right for you
okay I think that is our
completely the case because I have that
in meetings that I think creativity and
storytelling in itself is a timid
process because you are trying stuff out
constantly you're throwing stuff against
the wall see if it sticks you're not
sure that you have to see it's kind of a
yeah but in a meeting with producers I
think we talked about that also four
years ago you have to pretend as if you
have an all figured out there is no
doubt in your mind you see the movie
clearly all like I don't know a
single creative person who has a vision
the Hitchcock claimed that but he
basically had shot the movie in his mind
and maybe I don't know I know that
that's not the case with me or anyone
that I know but for some reason there's
this convention that everyone has to
pretend in those first meetings that you
have it all figured out otherwise you
won't get hired which I understand from
the producer and executive side because
of course you'd rather hire someone who
has the confidence that can take over
and you don't have to babysit that
person anymore
like if I put on to display all my
insecurities that I have about myself
the creative process the project the
idea all that kind of stuff in that
meeting you know I would be a mess and
the producer would seal and golly I
don't want to deal with that stuff I'm
hiring someone to shield me from all
that stuff yeah so I think that is a
personality thing like a lot of friends
of mine that I went to film school with
that I think are the better directors
don't work because they can't make it
through that first meeting because they
can't fake the confidence and the sort
meeting it's like an hour long you have
to pretend they should almost be an
acting class for directors to just act
confidently for an hour just get through
it somehow and pretend you know what
you're talking about because you don't
you at the beginning of the creative
process is that if you are meeting
someone and you're talking about
the plan to write a song you know that
doesn't exist yet there is no clear
vision of when you can talk about ideas
you can brainstorm you can talk about
what you don't want to do what you want
to avoid what you like you like the last
central movies like the darkness or
their referent
but to pretend that you have the product
already made in your mind I think it's
kind of insanity I mean do you think for
you a lot of the people maybe that you
know that we're in film school or people
that have talked to you after screenings
are making films because they're not
always shooting I know you said that in
the past always be shooting and I don't
know if that meant just on set always
have I'll be ready to roll or just even
during these down times they weren't
making something they weren't doing
something in terms you know I think that
goes to what you were saying earlier
about the that that people get gerd
easily if the feedback isn't positive
immediately so everyone's always waiting
for someone to give them to allow them
to believe in an idea to give them a
green light and go like go but no one
will you know so if you don't just go I
think that's what I meant by always be
shooting don't wait for someone else to
give you the green light or the money or
the support because it 99 percent won't
either and the people that are not
shooting other people that have been
developing the same script for 10 years
and they're waiting for financing for 20
mil for someone to give them twenty
million dollars that's not going to
happen you know I think the people that
are shooting other people that grab a
video camera and said I'm going to do
this quirky little thing now and see how
it turns out
and then they show to someone who see
something in it and then you go from
there but you need to be doing it rather
than waiting and hoping that someone
would allow you to do it and we have all
the tools today right there's no excuse
anymore to to wait because we just don't
need the same resources that we needed
20 years ago everyone can shoot a movie
on their iPhone but tangerine or oh what
does short films do you feel like after
maybe one or two as you talked about
being in film school it's with a safe
place to kind of fail
but then people that get caught in this
perpetual short addiction is that good
no no I think that is a problem because
it's just about how people look at stuff
if you haven't that might have been the
case years ago that someone would look
at a short film and go like this is
brilliant will now make the future
version of it but you can count and
those example examples exist but you can
count that on one hand I think what you
have to do today is you have to make a
feature as time-consuming it is you know
grueling as that is you have to get that
feature into a festival and you have to
get people to see it and it possible win
an award and that's the moment that
people will start paying attention and
will give you your next project because
they have to try to put yourself into
their mindset they have to justify why
they hire queue to their bosses right so
if you made a short film and you're next
want to do a feature you need someone
with brave and courageous enough to
close that gap for you and say I can
justify to my boss that on the basis of
this short film I gave you millions to
do this feature and I don't think there
are enough bright people out there
whereas if you have made a feature that
has won an award it's much easier for
this guy to go like well she has already
made a feature that won an award so I
didn't take any risk offering her this
new movie so this person is that movie
doesn't do well doesn't get fired yeah I
think it's all I think we talked about
that too less and it's all fear-based
people don't want to be seen taking
risks because it that goes badly they
lose their job so I think you have to
give them as much of a reason to trust
you with something that they can defend
when talking to that process as possible
that means make a feature I would after
film school urge everyone to not waste
time making short films when you sit
down to write a screenplay are you
focused on character plot certain set
pieces or is that the furthest thing
from your mind I haven't since old
school I've never
written anything by myself because it's
so daunting and you're so lonely and
it's so scary that I've never gone back
to that place it's always been writing
with someone and most of the time based
on material where there is already force
draft or there is a synopsis oh there's
something there that I have in front of
me rather than go into that scary place
of there's nothing and it has to come
out of nowhere and have been happy lucky
enough to to work with talented people
that can deal with that condition better
than I can
I think that's one of the reasons where
I went into directing over writing
because I couldn't really deal with the
anxiety of the blank blank page and
knowing that if I take the wrong turn
you know in x1 then three months later
I'll wake up in x3 and go like oh damn I
just wasted two months of my life
because I you know took the wrong turn
or was directing it's much easier
because you you see what you have in
front of you and you can criticize that
all you want and put the structure in
there you know but the initial process
of Inception I haven't been a part of in
a long time and I miss that a little bit
because that is the real creativity that
the writer comes up with but that's the
price you pay I guess we're not being a
great writer and I got a great vibe I
think it's a fear of being alone that's
interesting yes because it's just there
if you are alone or this in my
experience you're alone with your inner
critic you know in film school we learn
a lot of narrative structure and all
that kind of stuff so I apply that I
can't help it as soon as I come up with
an idea I throw all that technique on it
and there's nothing that doesn't die
under that blanket immediately you know
and this inner critic I've heard
different people talk about how they
deal with it that they have a notepad
and everything the inner critic says
goes on the notepad : and then in the
drawer and we will deal with that later
but now let us give the creative process
the freedom to not be suffocated by the
inner critic which I've never actually
tried a driver because it sounds great
but if you have someone else that you
can bounce ideas around with I think
it's so much faster because I don't have
to have an idea in my head and wait
until I know how I feel about that idea
I just say it I don't have to be afraid
that it's a stupid idea if I found a
good collaborator
and that person will have an immediate
reaction to it either good or bad if
it's bad then we go another direction if
it's good then I don't have to
second-guess myself and go like Oh help
that was good idea but I know that my
hundred percent of my test audience
right now that one person loved the idea
so we're good to go into that direction
of course there are a million ideas and
you throw out 99% of them but the second
person your co-writer gives you such a
safety net that I don't want to do
without ever again I sleep better with
it faking it have you tried ever right I
mean I know you wrote in college and if
you were an editor for school newspaper
or you you wanted to do short stories or
science fiction things like that yes so
never narrative long form since I
studied at FI directing I've never done
from scratch again maybe it's time 15
years later man
that trauma is not inside of me anymore
I don't know you can fight with the
critic on paper that's right you know
nothing away
exactly never look at it for a minute or
I know that I used that critic on a
daily basis when dealing with other
people's material and they must hate me
for it because I like if you give me
five pages of a script I'll give you 30
pages of notes on those five pages
because my inner critic just goes wild
in and that can be a blessing and a
curse I think it's on the one hand it's
good because it's all narrative
structure based but on the other hand of
course it stifles the creative the joy
of the creative project
advair the process a little bit there's
a saying that people don't actually want
feedback they just want reinforcement
that their idea is good and I'm the
wrong person to show your screenplay to
huh but yeah but then the people that
you think about the people that have
been in your test screens and then five
of them have come up
the same issue quote-unquote that they
have in your film isn't that almost a
blessing in total and not moving on that
moment but know it hurts but yes it's an
absolute blessing there is I think it's
an art to give feedback that at the same
time criticizes and boosts your
confidence very much and that's
interestingly I I've learned that la
people are actually pretty good at that
where's people outside of the leg like
if I show something to my German friends
that's when I noticed the difference
between if I have a test screening among
filmmaker friends in LA they know how to
gently put something but at the same
time go like but you're on to something
great here and if you keep going to that
direction it's going to be mind-blowing
whereas the German crowd just gota hated
it end of story
and you're like left hanging it kind of
destroyed I think that's a that's that's
an art that not many people know how to
do right you know I think - intention I
think some people give criticism to
wound but those people you the good
thing about having made several projects
that you leave out those people for the
next test screams don't ever don't ever
don't take advice about your writing
from someone that doesn't love your
writing and I think it's the same with
what filming like if someone hates the
film you want to make then that person
is not the one to help you get to where
you want to go obviously but I think
after a couple of times you have that
that down word goes the other way that
you know like I had the one girl in film
school at EV I without saying her name
but we were so different
in what we liked and what we were trying
to do and she hated everything I did so
much and I hated everything she did so
much that she became this really
valuable test viewing member because I
knew when she hated something I was on
the right track and when I screamed my
thesis film ruffcut she was the first
one
raised her head okay like I love this I
don't know we better go back into the
editing room and we edit that thing we
did after she became valuable just by
knowing what she offers has to do or is
into the loser so it could go either way
I think that yeah the people that won't
want to hurt you you should probably get
rid of as quickly as possible in your
new test screen but you also shouldn't
get rid of the people that tell you the
truth and I think that's one kind of
death the danger so if you're not
necessarily experiencing the blank page
but you're collaborating with someone
else's work who's already done that part
what's your process for then breaking
down that script looking at it analyzing
it well I'm the slowest reader in the
world draggable techniques six hours to
your script I don't know why that I've
kind of read it out loud in my head or
something
but what happens because of that is that
I am stuck in every single moment and
that script for a really long time so I
notice really quickly when something
takes tool whereas a quicker reader will
probably just go like oh here's a here's
a page of whatever and I'll just
continue reading on I get angry if I'm
on a page that doesn't know what at once
and I don't know why I'm in that scene
right now and I hope to write this out
very bad but I kind of quote the writer
personally responsible with wasting my
time which really isn't their fault
because I'm just a slow leader but at
least after reading it I have a very
clear and it might be completely off
objectively but I have a very clear idea
where I felt a script worked or didn't
work and then I just apply I'm a big
believer in formula as always were in in
classic narrative structure like from
Aristotle over I think Robert McKee is a
genius I know a lot of people think he's
to formulate these whatever but I think
that most of the weaknesses in
narratives when it can't hold your your
attention that is because it doesn't
adhere to a certain narrative structure
3x structure of 5x structure whatever it
is
that is ingrained in us as human beings
you know so I work a lot with question
marks for example like at what at what
moment at this moment in the script what
are the question marks that I as an
audience and burning to have answered
that made me turn the page why am i
interested in continuing this and a lot
of time you'll realize there is no
question mark that people are just
having coffee right now and you know
it's a problem in a prospector what
we're talking about earlier which is
conflict and stakes cost drama is
conflict and stakes that also means that
you don't know what the outcome of
something will be so there is a kind of
internal magnetism and a structure from
moment to moment that I think you have a
it's very easy to get a good feeling for
that I do not be distracted by that's
maybe another thing I'm not a very
visual person as and I don't see the
script in my head you know at all I feel
the story I read the story I get a
feeling for the characters I don't see
images and I think a lot of other people
that do see the images are kind of
seduced by that and don't necessarily
see that the story is weak in empathy
that the cornerstones of the story are
not as powerful as they should be but
because I don't have that visual at all
to distract me I'm always after the
moments that don't live up to their full
potential in what they are trying to do
and that's a very abstract thing that
doesn't matter if that happens on a boat
or in space or on whatever is you know
it's always the why should the audience
be at the edge on the edge of their seat
right now what are they wondering about
what do they want to find out why do
they care what do they identify with
those things you know so it's almost a
mathematical structure which helps me
not because it is basically more or less
to start the same starting point for
almost every script which of course a
lot of writers hate because they go like
but my script is different from them
that's good it is different in subject
matter and content but in the underlying
expectation and the rhythm that our
audience has in consuming a story it's
not different it's me that's net with
the same expectations so you have to see
it through that lens to know how an
audience is going to react to it I think
what is that preferred rhythm from what
you've seen is it pulses of conflict not
too soon but don't have too much
conflict for too long
give them a break for a second I mean I
don't know there's dance there's
standard a good thing but I think you
need the first act has to deliver the
dramatic question you know ideally there
is a protagonist who has a very clear
objective ideally there are stakes so
their consequences is that protagonist
doesn't succeed and the higher those
stakes the more dramatic the story
ideally there is a scene and there's a
whole book safe a cat but it's all based
on let ideally you have given the
audience a reason to side with that
protagonist which a lot of movies and
scripts leave out completely which is
amazing to me because one of the main
ingredients why would i as an audience
care if that character sees his father
before he dies you know there must be
something that shows me a humanity
inside of that character it can be a bad
bad mafia serial killer whatever guy but
something that I can relate to where we
share our humanity in that moment so
that he becomes the vehicle for me to
discover things about myself in the end
I think that's the secret that every
audience it's a very that's a very
selfish process I think every audience
really comes to the theater to learn
something about themselves and not about
Oklahoma or space or ever but about
their emotions in that moment but that
only works if you can create a
connection between the protagonist and
the audience earlier so that would
probably be the formula I'm looking for
is there a connection is there a clear
want which leads to the dramatic
question
is will this protagonist successfully
save the love of his life whatever
whatever and then you go into the second
act where there are where you have to
look at the conflicts is there enough is
what he accepts he is doing
are they escalating in a way that at the
same time is believable but also doesn't
need too much patience because when
realized he would probably first fall
his grandmother and then he would go to
die we don't sit through all that we
want the condensed version we want the
fake version that we wanted to feel
emotionally real which is a hard thing
to achieve but it was something that you
can very clearly track throughout a
second action I think and the first half
of the second act normally traditionally
is called like the fun and games part
which is where most the see of the
scenes that you see in a trailer are in
the first half of the second act where
the promise of the movie the reason why
people came is to see those scenes you
know it's like oh there's a man that
talks to his snake melt Mel Gibson with
his beaver and Jodie Foster's movie you
know that would be the first half of the
second act where we kind of have a
little bit of time the clock is ticking
quite as fast yet and then most of the
time the mid-point halfway through the
story is a more fundamental twist to the
whole story it turns out the beaver is
real or has whatever whatever you know
can actually talk up something that
changes our whole look on the story and
the direction of the story which i think
is super important because otherwise the
second act gets very long like if it's
only a one directional thing which
exists of course in peace exists
successfully but it's very hard to
execute to keep the audience's attention
without something that in the middle
kind of breaks the movie up and gives it
a whole different version and another
time again in a spy movie it would be
our protagonist finds out that the
agency he's working for us actually the
bad guys bubble bubble so suddenly is or
in Mad Max it's when they've been
driving into that one
direction and now they have achieved
whatever they need to achieve another
literally turning around coming back
that would be kind of the midpoint then
the stakes have to be raised in the
second half of the second act and lead
to the major confrontation then if you
go by the hero's journey which I believe
in a lot Joseph Campbell and all that
kind of stuff
there is the major confrontation it
looks like the hero is going to die he
metaphorically dies sheds his old ego we
learned something about himself that he
didn't know before this most of the time
painful and that enables him because he
doesn't break at that moment he almost
breaks you get him to the breaking point
and you can see that in almost every
movie that that is being done because we
need to really break a character to see
what he's made of right if you never
challenge a character you don't know
what he really hasn't said so you almost
break him and in that process of staring
death in the face metaphorically or the
office in a romantic comedy it would be
the girl is dating another guy you know
it doesn't to be death literally but
it's death of that so now our
protagonist learns something about
himself that was in his blind spot that
he didn't know before which now enables
him to be to use that as a tool to
change
that's why character arcs and
development are so important
become a different person and that
enables him to achieve the goal that he
hadn't been able to achieve before
nowhere in the third act where most of
the time he has to defend where he's
where he is challenged by the
antagonistic force that he's been
battling throughout the second act one
last time and that's where the big
dragon or Sauron or whatever we know
rears his head for the first text and
that he has to prove that the change
that he just went through is a permanent
one that can be challenged and he will
still survive with his old ego end of
story
so there will be at least three that is
the mythology that thousands of years
old you know paradigm that stories are
building you can go away from that
paradigm as much as you want but I think
it helps to know that that is what
audiences in
which of me are expecting a firm who
does that really great is Tarantino like
other figures anyone who knows this
story structure better and necess with
it and messes with your expectation
which is great but it's different from
not knowing and just writing something
into the blue and then wondering why
people don't identify with the
characters or aren't hooked to certain
developments or something so that would
be my my formula structure that I can if
I if I'm reading it and I am engrossed
then it doesn't matter you know if it's
a three act structure or whatever but if
I feel like my attention kind of drifts
or that I really care most of the time
the answer is in that structure that
somehow doesn't deliver what it needs to
do
favorite clothing line of a movie what
is it could be several different movies
Stan that's a good question
favorite clothing line of the movie
maybe Fight Club you met me at a strange
time in my life I always loved because
it's so dry I have I remember a lot of
clothing lines of the movie but they one
interesting thing about it L is that in
screenwriting class they taught us that
you can look in good scripts you can
look look at the very first line in a
script and the very last line in the
script and if it's written well then you
can see the character change in those
two lions or the the whatever the movie
was communicating to you is supposed to
be like one view of the world the first
loan and the changed view of the world
is the last line I haven't examined a
lot of scripts if that is actually the
case but I love the idea that ideally
that protagonist talks differently says
something different and most of the time
probably the opposite of what he said in
the beginning in the end if that
character changed that we talked about
you know that data and rebirth thing is
fully delivered that that might be the
case is that the case for you met me at
a strange point in my life I don't know
what the first line of Fight Club is I
would have to look that up I don't know
but that's the theory so looking at some
of your films was there an ending line
where you said no though we've got a
it's got to be delivered in a different
tone there has to be a different look in
the eye it's not why I envisioned every
single one because I think the cost
becomes the point where the movie takes
over and tells you what it wants to be
it's such a cliche line but it's so true
that that thing on the screen suddenly
is something different from what you
imagined that in my experience the
ending that I initially shot never works
I might as well for the next project
just not shoot an ending cut the film
together and then see what ending wants
to have
but with 13 sins at least I learned that
that at least shot two endings knowing
that and then I was likely to see which
ending presents itself and wants to be
itself more and that was interesting
because I usually am always for the
darker ending they not the darker the
darker the better because it has that
air of it's more intelligent or some
witch's nonsense why is it more
intelligent elegent if your protagonist
dies in the end then when he doesn't but
I always feel like I've delivered
Shakespeare there's death in the end
rather than happy Hollywood ending but
in 13th simply shot to annex one dark
one where the protagonist does die and
one lighter one where he doesn't and for
the first time when I played them both I
have the feeling I want the lighter one
because I have seen this character go
through all these trials and
tribulations before 90 minutes for two
hours he doesn't deserve to die like he
deserves I means too much to me to
sacrifice him at the end of the movie
you know and then we test screen both
movies and got the same feedback that
people say it's so dark please at least
give us an ending that is not even
darker than so it's not just the ending
line because except the look in his face
or something another thing that's
important is the end music it took us
forever for the light more lighthearted
version for 13 cents which are still
pretty dark to find the right end track
because that is how you release the
audience back into the world was that
stealing right it's a combination of the
last line of the last look of the last
image this is the crane shot that goes
back or Evanier is nature restore it or
what order you go in is it open-ended
order and then unfortunately I wish you
didn't have to but you kind of have to
show your hand a little bit by choosing
the end track that you're chosen because
it does give away what you want the
audience to feel we talked about that
earlier the you know how vulnerable you
are as a filmmakers the audience knows
what you're trying to make them feel at
which emotion you're trying to
manipulate them into nothing says that
more overtly then they're closing music
over the credits it took us forever to
try different
different music stuff and it was a
different movie every single time then
in the end we found one else just in
between where you where was not clear
what the movie wanted you to feel
hopefully which might be uncomfortable
for a lot of audience was like the one
you talked about with someone wants a
happy end and a kavika close up and they
would probably hate that ending to begin
with and then with that music as it
means that emotionally a little bit
ambiguous but I kind of loved that for
that ending that was the Bourne series
because the music from the first one I
can remember doesn't necessarily make me
feel like it's a total happy ending but
there's a promise in the music but it
doesn't mean that everything is rosy
that's what I'm trying to say I don't
you think it's a bit I don't remember
the specific scores but I think that's
exactly what you'd want it to be if it's
not a closed ending because everything
is rosy is not a very inch it's not a
very challenging now ending and if
you're trying to make a movie where
where people will gather in groups
outside of the theater to discuss and
the louder they're screaming at each
other the better because you're
succeeding you you know kind of if you
brought up emotions but let your own
opinion about it be as much on the
background as possible and let it be
ambiguous that to me feels very grown-up
because you're giving the audience
you're releasing them ideally with a
question and not with an answer that is
the addition at least whether that works
or not I don't know but I think great
great movies do that Fight Club does a
lot of interest movies to that last
function here for sure does that on a
great scheme or to direct questions
about humanity that you're being try to
know how the Bourne series handles that
but I could imagine that the characters
complex enough that you can't force them
into a clean cut it's the positive
ending kind of thing so that makes a lot
of sense to me aside from your screening
in Kosovo which we know you you could
not probably stand outside to listen to
some of the groups because there were
other issues going on but from other
maybe more tame
screenings have you sort of lingered
outside just to hear even the intensity
and the discussion not even the words
being said but the the the passion in
someone who voiced when they were
debating with a friend over something
not in my own with my own movie so much
because I'm mostly in the Q&A and that
discussion happens right there in the
audience which I love that sometimes
happens that one person asked the
question and then somewhere in the
audience just when I'm about to answer
answers that question but in with an
attitude and then that person is there
is something happening and the more of
that happens but better you know the
more involved people feel doesn't mean
they love the movie necessarily some
people might hate them when we would
have a very strong opinion about
something and then that triggered
globalism but I've seen it with other
movies wings of desire when I first
watched Wings of Desire there was the
afternoons when when thin didn't then
there's wind winters other hood fittings
there was the afternoon show I arrived
for the evening show there were all
these people this little group standing
from the theater debating as if it was
like college course or something now
it's like well I'm fine I wonder what
movie I'm getting myself into here you
know about breaking the waves I think
the same thing where people break the
ways to me is one of those movies that I
can't I watch it every single time and
screamed somewhere because every time
I'm hoping that this time she's going to
make it this time she's going to survive
I know it's a movie it's probably going
to end the same way it ended last time
but that character has me so much that
for some reason she's become real to me
and I am you know following her wherever
she's screening within hundred miles
breaking the web and after that movie I
can never talk but a lot of people can
and there are the most particular hater
or lover or but everyone has a
relationship with the protagonist you
know and that is definitely one of the
movies that leads to discussions outside
of the movie theater
that's an interesting feeling when you
really wouldn't you just speechless and
you can't even make small talk yes after
a film I've been there many times and
you have to maybe use the bathroom or
you have to go get a drink of water or
something and yet to the base human
being with music might take days oh wow
I want to go home as quickly as possible
and that's not just when something is
tragic I felt like that after the
revenant I'm like it's just being
overwhelmed by either the filmmaking
quality or the protagonists state in the
story or something you know it's like it
has to be a pretty bad movie for me to
want to discuss it with someone right
afterwards you know another bad movie
but if you know someone that does not
have its hooks in me so much that I will
think about it in a week or two to come
do you think that's an introvert
extrovert issue because I wonder if
because introverts are so internal and
that's not to say extroverts don't feel
things in our internal at times but
extroverts need to vocalize right so
much where is introverts really just
stance they just let it ruminate and we
kind of have to work it out in our own
heads I think that it's always another
thing that that extroverts get energy
from contact with other people in
introverts sucks energy out of them
right and they gain energy from being
internal I think by themselves so that
would make sense to me that if I'm
already so exhausted emotionally by the
movie I have no more energy to give so I
can't interact with people that which
was then we require more energy because
I don't have that energy I just need to
go home and we yeah gain that energy or
something I don't know that's
interesting
have you ever had trouble even driving
and sometimes it's like I think I need
to pull on a side street just so you're
like it after certain films something I
could no okay but that was me don't
don't drive emotionally impacted other
let's move it